anyone who has even a passing interest
in eSports has probably heard of Lee
faker Sankhya he's a once-in-a-lifetime
talent a three-time world champion the
face of League of Legends and
unanimously considered to be the
greatest to ever play the game but that
wasn't always the case in 2013 he was
still making a name for himself a gifted
yet unproven player pulled from the
ranks of solo queue to lead SK Telecom
t1 K into a new era
however with OGN broadcasts held behind
a paywall and LOL esports still growing
many European and North American fans
who had heard the rumblings from Korea
hadn't yet witnessed faker in action
firsthand but that all changed on
September 7th 2013
when faker pulled off a play that would
stun his opponent and the world alike
this is the faker versus ryu outplay
it's the grand finals of the 2013 hot
six champions summer and sk telecom t1 k
are taking on the kt rolster bullets SKT
t1 k had breached through their group
and the first two rounds of the playoffs
only dropping a single game but here
they found themselves under serious
pressure the kt rolster bullets had
seized at UNO lead in the series before
SKT t1 k got on the board with two
consecutive wins of their own to force a
deciding game
this was it one last blind pick match to
crown the champion
faker locked in Zed Ryu did the same it
was game on Katie took an early lead the
pain train is coming through the river
there's stuff here on the impact he goes
down as well but around the 20-minute
mark the tide began to turn in SKT t1 K
a double kill already four piglets on
you trying to escape in sick we need
something he won't get it within
touching distance of his first lck title
faker overstepped and Ryu threw down the
gauntlet in one of the most brilliant
displays of decision-making and
mechanical skill ever faker despite
starting at a significant disadvantage
completely outplay Ryu to win the gutsy
duel the look on re-use face and the
absolute shock of Doha and Monte Cristo
told the entire story before we get into
the play it's important to note that
despite his team being massively ahead
faker is not actually that far ahead of
Ryu at all but the one key item
difference is the Quicksilver sac which
at the time could cleanse off the zed
ultimate and it's damaged the play
starts with faker taking tower shots and
reuse e auto attacks and blade of the
ruined King active under tower putting
the SKT mid laner under half health
after we use passive hits a faker then
uses his own blade of the room eating
active to steal moose feed and try to
run away at this point
Ryu ignites him hoping to clean up the
kill before faker gets away
faker responds with his ultimate making
him invulnerable and allowing him to
avoid damage from Ryu and his ignite Ryu
responds with his own death mark to
avoid trading kills he then miss judges
fakers movements throwing a shadow
upwards instead of down
faker avoids it by jumping to his shadow
downward here the item difference saves
fakers life he Quicksilver sashes the
death Mark and the Ignite freeing him
from all damage he then sneaks in a
queue ignite and auto attack against Ryu
before dodging reuse queue and canceling
reuse Auto Attack with a flash to the
left the slimmest of margins determines
the end of this fight as Ryu attempts to
flash the faker to secure the kill with
an auto attack Ryu gets his auto
cancelled once more this time by fakers
definitely which he didn't use this
entire time faker then uses e to finish
when the clip hit the web it exploded
the global league community marveled at
fakers incredible exhibition and the
young Korean star quickly became a
household name you have to understand
that for most Western fans in 2013
seeing the play for the first time was a
revelation sure the outplay didn't alter
the course of the game SKT t1 K was
already poised to win but it did change
the course of League history
everyone who watched that outplay knew
that they were witnessing greatness and
that faker would be a player to keep an
eye on for years to come and the
unkillable demon king has not
disappointed where the Terr used to be
nice upper survive gets cusan and pilot
now it's the knock-up so faker gets very
low but SKT all over this teamfight
again coming through is absolutely
devastate now six domestic titles and
three World Championships later it seems
obvious that faker was destined to
become the greatest player of all time
but it all started with an amazing
outplay that put Ryu and the rest of the
world on notice
at the meadow Baker may be in trouble
your death mark tries to cleaning up for
real
oh look at the glass look at the bows
thank you what was that
faker with a UI lay the qss I can't put
a virus though you actually want that
jewel thanks for watching if you want
more great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]